[Musique]
le département et ses partenaires
présentes la sixième édition du Salon
des Seniors de la Réunion une
manifestation à destination des 50 ans
et plus ainsi qu'à leur famille quatre
jours de fête avec un programme riche en
divertissement
25000 personnes accueilli gratuitement
donc et c'est là le rôle du département
à travers sa contribution financière de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse venir sans
avoir à payer quoi que ce soit et là on
va découvrir des stands donc des
animations avec une sensibilisation
beaucoup d'informations sur les aides
qui sont apportées à nosseignants et
cette manifestation sera clôturée le 29
octobre à Saint-Denis avec un grand
rassemblement c'est le grand
rassemblement de la fin du mois
d'octobre que nous offrons tous nos
saignons l'occasion de se retrouver de
partager des moments de s'informer et de
repartir
content d'avoir vécu de grands au sein
du Salon des Seniors plus de 25000
personnes sont attendues à Saint-Pierre
les 9 et 10 septembre prochain et à
Saint-Denis les 28 et 29 octobre au
jardin de l'État pour cette édition 2023
c'est l'humoriste Sully rivière qui
paraît la manifestation heureux et
moi-même d'être avec
ce dimanche à Saint-Pierre parce que non
inspectables pour propose aux autres et
qui cadrera bien avec le monde dans
lequel nous sera et tout simplement que
non seulement il est permis de bien
vivre mais toujours permis de bien rire
Renaud Sadon et Joel Bègue animeront
aussi la fête 9 villages thématiques
seront ouverts toute la journée pour
cette grande fête des seniors
[Musique]